today it is my honor to sit down with dr
alina chan
to talk about the origin what we do and
do not know about the origin of sars
cov2 the virus that causes cobit 19.
this is going to be one of those videos
that is controversial
i might end up losing a bunch of
subscribers because of this one but
that's okay this topic is very important
to me i
have thought long and hard about who i
would have on to talk about this we're
going to talk about the lab league
hypothesis and we're going to go into
some some detail on that
dr chan has just written a book on the
topic she is a genetic engineer at the
broad institute of mit and harvard one
of a handful of scientists who have been
hammering home the fact that we need to
investigate the possibility that this
was a lab origin to be clear she's not
saying that this was a bio weapon but it
might have been an accident in a medical
research laboratory one of the reasons
this this topic is so interesting to me
is that almost two years ago i published
an animation on the stated clearly
channel that's that's my main youtube
channel the video is called where do new
viruses come from the backstory behind
that is that back in january of 2020
january 28th to be exact i was stuck at
an airport in panama and i noticed that
a bunch of people were wearing masks so
i asked what was happening and people
told me that there was this virus that
came out of china
and i wanted to find a nice quiet place
to read about it so i found this chapel
it's just a normal airport room but
they turned it into what looks like one
of those little churches that you would
find just on a random street in south
america sat down in there underneath the
fake stained glass windows
next to baby jesus i read about this new
coronavirus from the world health
organization website and i was looking
very carefully at the data me and baby
jesus we decided you know what i think
this is probably going to happen this
was going to hit north america as soon
as i got home i started making an
animation explaining what viruses are
how they work and how it is that they
normally jump from animals to humans
normally this happens naturally while
studying the coronavirus obviously i
learned that there is a laboratory the
wuhan institute of virology
right next to where it broke out and so
even though i wanted the focus of this
video to be about the natural origin
hypothesis that's how viruses normally
spread i did mention this
others suggest that the virus may be an
escaped lab specimen now this actually
is possible viruses have escaped from
research labs in the past but as of the
time that i'm recording this voiceover
investigations into this idea have not
yet reached any solid conclusions
could there be another more natural
explanation for the origin of this virus
the answer is yes
covid19
the new human infecting coronavirus may
have simply evolved from an older animal
infecting coronavirus
this one little sentence right here
this actually is possible viruses have
escaped from research labs in the past
that one little sentence got me into a
bunch of trouble
with my audience i had letters people
telling me that i was spreading it
conspiracy theory i had letters saying
that i was enabling racism and so on and
this is because
there's a bunch of different reasons for
this one reason is that
donald trump had been
obnoxious
about this at this point you know at
first he was saying that the virus was
going to be no big deal then he blamed
it on the world health organization you
know that was really funny that he says
the world health organization didn't
warn us
ahead of time when you know a month
before he was complaining about this i
had figured this out at the airport
by just
reading the world health organization's
website on my phone so the fact that
donald trump didn't think he got enough
warning from them is ridiculous but
anyways that's a different different
topic but probably the biggest reason
people were rejecting the possibility
that this could have come from a lab the
reason they were upset with me in saying
that i was spreading a conspiracy theory
is that this letter was published in the
lancet in case you're not aware the
lancet is a scientific journal it's a
medical journal they publish research
from scientists and they also publish
sort of you could think of as opinion
pieces they call them correspondence
letters and this letter was published
called
the statement in support of the
scientists public health professionals
and medical professionals of china
combating covet 19. this was written by
a bunch of very prominent virologists
and together they said this we stand
together to strongly condemn conspiracy
theories suggesting that covet 19 does
not have a natural origin
now the way that everyone interpreted
that sentence is that
the lab leak hypothesis is a conspiracy
theory
well that's garbage okay because
there is a laboratory in wuhan just
several miles away from where the virus
first was detected
that studies coronaviruses
not only do they study coronaviruses
they genetically modify coronaviruses
one of the most significant coronavirus
research labs in the world is right at
the center of where this broke out so of
course a lab leak is possible well it
turns out that almost two years later
we still don't know i'm recording this
on
december 14 2021
and we still don't know
definitively if this came from a lab or
not china didn't want people to
investigate that laboratory and recently
there was an investigation by the world
health organization that was supposedly
an independent investigation turns out
that some of the people that were in
charge of that ended up having really
close ties to this laboratory and again
alina talks about that today
but
they were not allowed to investigate the
lab and so there's been a call from
scientists including alina but also many
others
for a thorough investigation of that
laboratory and just this drama here this
this accusation that maybe there was a
spillover and some scientists saying no
that's a conspiracy
this
this has caused just a horrible division
within the scientific community and it's
involved a lot of people that i know and
care about and it's just been very
frustrating for me to see and so i sat
down here with alina chan dr alina chan
to talk about this some of the the
mudslinging that's been happening to her
um it just
we want to get to the bottom of this
so
the conversation that we had
is very very important because
for a couple of reasons first of all
it's a conversation about the integrity
of the scientific project itself
like can science withstand controversy
like what we're seeing right now
but the answer is i think yes of course
it can of course we're going to heal
from this but
it
it's tricky
and then the other really important
question that we talk about is
what are we doing in these virology
research labs and is it safe the answer
to that is no it's not safe
but
i do think that we can make it a lot
safer
and so we discuss these things this is a
very very important conversation so
without further ado i give you my
conversation with dr alina chan
what hypotheses do you think are still
on the table and which hypotheses have
been ruled out there are two main
plausible scenarios one is a natural
origin and this is a story we've heard
thousands of times especially from
virologists and infectious diseases
experts because they have seen it
hundreds of times
there are always natural viruses
crossing from animals to humans and so
some of these examples include when a
human goes into a cave with millions of
bats and they breathe in like a pathogen
so they can catch it that way or another
popular route is through the wildlife
train so when there's a lot of different
species of wild animals being shut
through the animal trafficking circuit
across
borders across provinces and through
that way through that interaction
between animals and humans viruses can
jump
on the other hand you look at the lab
origin and there's also a whole spectrum
of different activities so the most uh
basic one is when a scientist or team of
scientists goes into these caves or
markets and samples not only animals but
even humans who are suspected to be
infected with these normal viruses
during that process of something they
might themselves get sick because you're
in a cave
you're surrounded by millions of bats
and they're all pooping everywhere and
flying everywhere and biting you so
there's obviously a chance of you
getting sick and bringing that back to
your city
uh but there's also an enhanced level of
this so once you bring the virus back to
your city once all these tens of
thousands of samples in your lab you
could start drawing growing these
viruses you could find their genetic
code and
create completely new virus copies in
your lab you could insert novel
modifications you might even
accidentally enhance these viruses and
in that process from just growing it to
maybe enhancing the virus you might get
infected and accidentally bring that out
into your city right what you've laid
out there too is that even with a lab
leak
there's a natural origin that comes from
a lab leak like
if someone is just cultivating a virus
or trying to grow a virus in the lab
that they captured in the wild you know
from a fecal sample or something
i mean that really is just a natural
spillover event too it's just that it
happened through a lab instead of
through a meat market when we first
heard about this in in january 2020 i
think there were very few people who
thought that it came from a lab it was
only later as
evidence failed to
present itself pointing to a natural
origin that people started to worry that
maybe it's not just a coincidence that
all of all the cities in china
this sars-like virus
imploded on the doorsteps of a
lab that is known for collecting the
most diverse satellite viruses and that
out all the possible viruses that could
emerge in a chinese city it was a size
like virus so
i i think that that
the balance of evidence has shifted a
lot in the past one and a half years so
in the beginning i'd say that a lot of
people felt quite confident that this
was just a repeat of sas one that it's
just a matter of time that they would
find the original animal host like maybe
a pangolin or raccoon dog but two years
later nothing has showed up and instead
there has been more and more leaked
documents or litigated documents showing
that scientists in that city were
conducting extremely risky research the
type that might possibly generate a
virus that looks like saskoff too but it
should have been obvious from the start
though that we have to investigate
all of these options right
and we did have the us intelligence
immediately was investigating the
possibility that this was a bio weapon
and immediately investigating the
possibility this was a this was a lab
leak
but they were doing that fairly quietly
i think that's totally appropriate you
don't you don't want to you know it's
innocent until proven guilty right
but
even if you're innocent until proven
guilty you have to do an investigation
you know you
you have to you have to look into those
possibilities i mean we're we're in a
time period in history where
all of these things are now possible the
only thing that you've been saying in
your research is that we need to keep
looking into
a lab leak possibility
that all you're saying is that has not
been ruled out we are just now starting
to see a lot of emails uh from early
2020 being litigated being released
online and these showed the private
deliberations amongst some of the top
virologists and top infectious diseases
experts in the west so in europe and in
the us
and it showed that they were very
concerned about that origin of south
korea
one of them a major general who has seen
since like passively unfortunately he
even expressed that he he felt that the
evidence pointed to a lab origin of of
this virus and he said that it was
because the evidence pointing to the
market was flimsy he he said that all
the cover-up
seemed to point to with this lab origin
that they replace the leadership at the
ohana city of biology
that no one could get any access or
information on the origin of this virus
and that no animal host has been found
so
i suspect that there were a lot of
sensible experts who considered the lab
origin very seriously and thought it was
plausible but the climate wasn't
appropriate for them to raise it
some of them have
said in their emails that they're
worried that it will cause panic they
would fuel conspiracy theories so
for better or worse they they tempt down
on the lab origin hypothesis like as a
group collectively they everything from
an accident to a bio weapon they
classify the all as one
lamb origin hypothesis and threw it out
as a conspiracy theory so
i think that that was a mistake because
when you do that when you withhold
information because you're worried that
the public cannot handle it and then the
public finds out later that you lied to
them because
you don't trust them to handle
information well then it makes them
really suspicious of any future
announcement from you they're like are
they hiding stuff again because they
think we can't handle it very early on
and actually before i had published my
video my first video on this
everyone in the news was saying that a
lab leak of any kind is a conspiracy
theory
i mean technically i guess you're right
because if if there's a lab leak and
people covered it up then there is a
conspiracy to cover up a lab leak right
but the
it's it's not like a tin foil hat
conspiracy theory so people the the
media had already dismissed the
possibility of a lab leak immediately
and there is a good precedent for this
you know we had every time there's a
virus people say that it's it was
engineered so hiv people said was
engineered it's like we're not allowed
to just have a natural origin of
something anymore people will always
want to freak out and say that it was a
mad scientist that did it well i have i
have to say that
there will always be conspiracy
theorists right there will be always
people on extreme ends and that includes
the experts who threw out the lamb
origin as a conspiracy they are also
extremists so
we can't the people in the middle like
us we can't let these people on the
extreme ends determine what
information the public can have like
that that's crazy that they say that
because because like point one percent
of the population can't handle it
therefore like all of us cannot know the
truth like that that is ridiculous um
and to this point about um
about lab about people who always jump
to the conclusion that it's it's lame
and stuff
yes it's kind of like this the boy who
cried wolf kind of situation right but
we can't let things that happen like a
century ago
dictate dictate today's signs so like we
have to look at what is happening today
what what is the evidence today we we
can't just look at historical precedence
and if even if you look at historical
precedence there have been plenty of
natural spillovers yes but there have
also been plenty of lab escapes even the
first sars virus once it started being
studied in laboratories it escaped at
least six times including from a top
biosecurity lab once so
and actually recently we have heard news
from taiwan that sas corp 2 was being
studied in the bsl tree so a pretty high
security level and it still escaped in
fact it's someone who was double
vaccinated with moderna so we shouldn't
underestimate the risk of lab escapes
yeah let me let me say that again so
that
the audience is very clear on this
we just had a new lab leak escape of
sars cove ii so this new the kova 19
virus from you know researchers that
were
looking into it right now
and so we know we know that this can
happen we know this is possible
and one of the big differences between
modern times and even back when when hiv
came out is that nowadays we have
tons of labs that are studying viruses
and
for some reason a lot of these labs are
in the middle of huge cities with
international airports
and so we have to consider this every
time that there is an outbreak we we
cannot ignore this possibility that it
was a laboratory accident and that's not
to be mean to researchers that's not uh
it's not to be mean to china it's not
this isn't an issue of racism or
xenophobia this is just
like we have to consider this
i have been
brokenhearted really by
what i've seen watching
what's supposed to be a scientific
discussion a scientific debate turn into
just
childish behavior i feel like the
scientific
discussion has broken down and it's it's
very disappointing to see
people have been demonized i've seen you
be demonized on twitter and so on i've
seen top scientists
say that you're an ignorant postdoc and
and then on the other side of things you
have dayzak and fauci and and uh jung
lee being just
turned into monsters you know
and it's
it's insane to see what's happened
because what we care about is trying to
figure out how this virus started and
that should be it but of course there's
a lot of
political reasons that's that's not
really all that's happening here so i
actually want to speak about the point
that you you raised like and it's really
important to remember that scientists
are people scientists are human beings
too so it's not that once you get your
graduate degree in science you suddenly
become a saint
you're still human you're still
followable i have made mistakes top
scientists have made mistakes there has
to be room to make mistakes and to own
up to mistakes because in the world
where people cannot own up to mistakes
that means you're either a god or you're
cancelled
and and it's it's
that's what we're seeing right now is
that some scientists are
being
like put on a pedestal to a point where
they cannot acknowledge their mistakes
to the point where they have to defend
their divinity
over
defending the scientific method which
allows rooms for repeated mistakes we
learn from our mistakes and so this
whole saga of searching for the origin
of kovan 19 has been a master class in
looking at how the scientific community
can be very conflicted
how science cannot be embodied by one
person or even a group of people like
science is a process that a lot of
people feed into
interdisciplinarily so it's not
something where a pandemic happens and
only virologists can have the answer so
for example one of the most critical
principles of this pandemic that this
virus is airborne
that you can catch it from breathing the
air when there's sick people who are
breathing air in the same room that that
principle has been pushed forward most
strongly not by virologists but by
aerosol scientists like scientists who
study in the physics of of aspirate of
viruses transmitting to the air and so
it has been a lesson of humility for a
lot of us what has happened to the
collaborations between chinese and u.s
scientists when i look at what peter
desect did early on when he wrote this
letter for the lancet saying that an
artificial origin is a conspiracy it's
really inappropriate for a scientist to
be saying something like that but i also
feel like maybe
he was he had good contact with his
chinese collaborators and then all of a
sudden the government was getting
between them he couldn't talk to them he
was scared about their safety their
well-being he was trying to do something
to
ease the pressure between the u.s and
china so that he could actually figure
out what the heck happened are chinese
researchers able to communicate freely
with american researchers or is this
is there silencing happening
i'm sure that there's sign silencing
happening so we know that the chinese
government
started putting gag orders on not just
its own city sea
at the center for disease control but
also its own researchers so people told
if you want to publish anything on the
origins you have to get approved at like
three or four different levels including
government level approval so clearly
this was a taboo topic and anyone who
wanted to preserve their lives and
safety would stay away from this topic
we know that china has disappeared or
thrown
citizen journalists into prison like
torture like
some of them for many years in prison
like unreasonable just for just for
going to ohan just for taking videos in
just for going around on the streets
asking people what do you think of the
government response how could that be
worthy of a prison sentence
so
as a scientist looking at that you
you know that people in china are not
free to speak their minds like
even if it's the hottest gossip on earth
like they cannot just
tell everybody and then their whole
family gets disappeared so um i think
that there has to be some
critical thinking here that the people
in china live in a very different
culture and it's not a judgement of
their moral character you have to
understand that in very challenging
situations um
so i've heard a lot of scientists
in the us and and and the uk and other
european countries they're like don't
you trust these chinese scientists i'm
like yeah i want to trust them but you
you shouldn't understand that they're
not in a situation where they can speak
freely it seems like
horrible ignorance on our part for
the collaboration that we had with the
with the wuhan laboratory without being
able to see everything that was
happening it seems like before the us
was collaborating with with the
laboratory they should have had access
to everything that was being done there
full transparency and we didn't set that
up and it's pretty amazing that we
didn't because you know we had
the the pentagon knew about all this
research that this this went through
every major approval
agency that you could think of in the us
and still we
as soon as this virus hit we were
completely blind as to what was
happening in that laboratory or maybe
it's only the public that's applying to
it maybe maybe the us actually knows
everything but i i suspect that they
don't i mean they're reporting that they
don't i think that they do know more
than we give them credit for so yeah
i've heard that some of the classified
information is very important and and
can help shed light on where the origin
of cover 19 is and so i've heard that
the majority of senators want this
information to be declassified so i'm
looking forward to that moment
furthermore we know from the recently uh
published declassified summary from the
u.s intelligence community that
one of their agencies the fbi according
to the new york times believes with
moderate confidence that this virus came
from a lab
another four agencies start with low
confidence that this was natural and
another three of them said we don't know
so i'd say that out of these agencies it
looks like the only one with a moderate
confidence says is from a lab and the
fbi they have access to a lot of
information in the u.s and i believe
that there is enough information outside
of china and the u.s and many other
places where there are collaborators of
chinese scientists that there are enough
pieces to put together a pretty clean
picture of what might have been
happening in uhan for me it makes sense
that individual researchers like peter
dezek and and
and so on
they would have had full confidence in
their chinese collaborators because
like
when i go to a science conference
everybody just
there's no international
issues everyone is just hanging out
together
and trusting each other and working
together
and we end up just developing this
confidence which is
sort of naive because of course
there are these huge
political conflicts that are happening
behind the scenes between nations all
the time
but that melts away in the scientific
community and it makes a lot of sense to
me that that scientists weren't
aware of the dangers of being so open in
their collaborations with each other
because we don't feel that tension in
the scientific community we don't feel
that that political tension but but it
does seem weird to me that the the
pentagon was not totally on top of that
but but you're saying you think that
they were you're saying that you think
that they probably had back channels to
really see what was happening
from the start so what we heard was that
even in early 2020
many
u.s intelligence and government
officials were already seriously
considering the lab origin so they
weren't saying that the virus came from
a lab but they were investigating so
clearly they thought it was plausible uh
the issue though is that
a lot of um
a lot of leaders place a lot of faith
and scientists so sometimes they take
the word of scientists as like
good to go like 100 factual so
they don't look at conflicts of interest
they don't even check if the data exists
which is very problematic extremely
problematic especially when it's
journalists who are reporting uh
or interviewing scientists and they
don't even check like does the data
exist that's very dangerous because
you're giving these scientists who again
are human beings who have
human incentives
you're just taking everything they say
for for truth for like 100 fact-checked
i don't need to check it anymore so that
this whole situation this whole search
for the origin has revealed all these
loopholes and not just the research
system the research publishing system
but even in journalism and in just like
regular journalism is that that there
isn't there isn't a strong
uh community of journalists who can
credibly evaluate what scientists are
telling them i'm not a journalist i i
make science animations for high school
classrooms
and i depend on scientists to fact check
my stuff for me and i feel like a lot of
science journalism is like this too it's
not like other types of journalism where
people are going in and being really
critical of everything that they hear
they're they're trying to build
relationships with scientists
so that they can get those scientists to
collaborate with them for free
the scientists already do lots of things
for free
yeah yeah and so if you look at the
beginning of this pandemic what we had
on this chess bond was that you had all
of these top science journalists and
writers and communicators and they
already had their pre-existing networks
of scientists that they trusted so even
there was a in new york times journalist
who wrote that um yeah he was such good
friends with dr anthony fauci and good
friends of dr peter dashang he believed
they would never lie to him and so he he
was writing to say that now he has
backtracked and even grown to love the
lab leak hypothesis but i mean it was
indicative of this bias is that when all
of your good friends are telling you
yeah it's a conspiracy theory to say
it's from a lab then you tend to go
along with that because you've trusted
them for so long like why would they
suddenly lie to you or with whole facts
from you and then boom all of a sudden
we see that peter daschak has all of
these conflicts of interest that if it
were ever confirmed to have come from a
lab like his whole organization would be
gone like his reputation gone his legacy
gone like the whole thing all this work
that they said was meant to prevent the
pandemic
might have caused the pandemic like it's
a lot to swallow
for for the organization for the world
and for peter deshak himself so it's
unfortunate that a lot of the
journalists reporting on this topic
just rested on the laurels of their
existing networks they had zero
skepticism i can tell you too from just
from someone who's doing science
communication
for me to burn bridges with the
scientists that i work with would end my
career because you know i've built i've
built these relationships over a long
period of time if i were to make them
angry that could be that could cause
major issues for me so there's a bunch
of little motivations that are that have
been guiding everything that really did
mislead us in the beginning of this
and i think one of the
one of the big ones is we had
years of donald trump
i mean he got on
i don't know how closely you followed
him but
he got on tv
it was one of his rallies he was calling
the coronavirus the kung flu he was just
he was he was making these comments that
would have been clever for like a 12
year old boy to say and you you might
laugh and then be like okay don't say
stuff like that but it's the president
of the united states of america saying
this
and so you have this on top of all you
know part of the the
the pieces that were set out on this
chessboard you have you have just the
way that science journalism was already
set up working against us
you have
this
we've got a president who's
being
childish in his accusations that a lot
of people are interpreting as being
racist and you know at the very least
you say they're extremely disrespectful
tom cotton is our politician who really
started driving home that we need to
look into a lab leak
and
he is very rough to listen to i don't
know if you've ever like sat and
listened to tom cotton talk about china
but he seems
i don't know if he actually is really
hateful but he comes across as being
really hateful and so you
you just you get this feeling of like
okay we know what this guy's motives are
he hates china
so there was all of this suspicion that
journalists had that the the lab leak
thing was something that people say if
they're hateful so all of that was on
the table
i'd say it's even in the it's even still
on the table because now we're being
treated to all these uh
theater between uh rand paul and and dr
anthony fauci yeah uh and and it's just
it's just a huge distraction to a
clearly very scientific problem is that
the scientific problem here is
did covet 19
emerge because of research activities
are we doing our pathogen research in a
transparent and safe way it doesn't
matter who all these random people are
saying things like
this central
scientific question that needs to be
addressed before another one of these
pandemics happens and we don't know
where it came from and like millions of
people are dying when we have to fix
this problem and you write all of these
little personal stories that are so
engaging it's so fun to watch
people like people in the us are
addicted to reality tv and this is like
another form of that to them like they
just love people like calling names to
each other saying crazy things on tv
it's like uh yeah but how about doing
actually something like taking actual
measures to prevent the future pandemic
and it's been shocking but there's been
zero measures taken to prevent the
future pandemic not not for natural and
not for
not for lab based pandemics like zero
has been done like china said that they
they shut down the trade of animals for
for consumption like wildlife animals
for consumption but the they didn't do
anything about the wildlife trade for
traditional chinese medicine or fur or
luxury goods so there's still still like
most of the wildlife train you know all
these civic cats right condolences the
fur and like pangolins it's the medicine
and then with the labs like it's just
you see more and more of these labs just
proliferating around the world like
china said they will build one bsl for
the top biosecurity level lab in every
province by 2025 and one of the southern
provinces says they'll build 20 bsl
trees in that single province and you're
seeing other countries copying this like
saying i'm gonna start my new bsl4 lab
in singapore and the city where some
seven million people live in a very
concentrated area i'm gonna have a bsl
fall like that so like
that i think people are huddling
in the wrong direction
you have written a book which you mainly
focus on the evidence suggesting a lab
leak origin i've seen online criticism
that you didn't give enough time to the
natural origin hypothesis but of course
that's what everyone else has been
giving time to so i don't see why you
would have to devote half of your book
to that you know i think they're very
they're very shocked by the book because
it's the first time they've seen the two
hypothesis put basically on par because
in the media it's just like everyone's
just like oh yeah you can't rule out a
lab origin but it's extremely unlikely
and this the book says no actually it's
quite likely it's quite plausible
uh we we do spend quite a bit of time
talking about how natural origin uh how
natural spillovers happen we talk a lot
about natural uh outbreaks and how these
are tracked and investigated and we even
end the book with a pretty strong robust
like steel man like not not a straw man
but a steel man argument for a natural
origin so in my view i think that we
have done our best to be as factual as
possible and to lay out the evidence not
not not writing it in the emotional way
or anything just letting the readers
know like this is what happened for
anyone who really wants to understand
the facts
surrounding the live league hypothesis
your book is the place to go for that
one of the things that's missing in the
book is your story
it was a very matter-of-fact book it was
very really well done actually that's my
favorite type of book is that just gets
to the point thank you but i do want to
get to the world a little bit of who you
are tell us about growing up and what
got you interested in science in the
first place you're canadian but you also
spent time in singapore
yes
i was born in canada but my parents
brought me back to singapore uh where
they are originally from
um
i
i was thinking about how to answer this
question and brought back a lot of
memories of growing up in singapore uh
honestly i wasn't a very good model
student like i actually was a truant so
i skipped a lot of classes i almost got
to bring up like expulsion
when i was like thirteen i was 14 years
old um but i had this homeroom teacher
and this like form teacher who who
turned everything around for me like and
it's kind of shocking but she she told
me to just go to this like mathematics
after school like class where you would
just sit there and spend a few hours
thinking about how to solve mathematical
problems and
somehow that that saved me like
i i was i was really close to just being
kicked out i could have been like a high
school dropout
but she she turned it around and that's
how i found like my
just like this really keen curiosity of
like trying to understand
um how to solve problems in mathematics
i know that sounds like super boring but
there's some mathematical problems that
just like almost like riddles like
trying to figure out how to how to crack
these um and and that was like the
gateway into science for me
because science has a lot of this too
and they may not be as as beautiful as
mathematics but so pure you can just you
know calculate and everything's numbers
but in the sciences there's a lot that's
really curious too and actually it was
viruses that got me really hooked like i
started uh i remember learning about hiv
this virus that could hijack the immune
system the thing that is set up in your
body to to attack and eliminate
pathogens and so for me it became a
riddle in itself that how do you fight
off a virus that fights the system that
is meant to eliminate viruses so let us
carry it on
and
somehow either i found my way
uh
i went back to canada uh for a bit of
high school and then went straight to
university so i was pretty young at the
time
um and i kept doing like really at once
mathematics and stuff but i ultimately
decided to stay in biology and
biochemistry and genetics because to me
this genetics is a different kind of
mathematical puzzle
with biological implications like
figuring out which genes
affect like different diseases or
different health conditions that kind of
thing and i eventually got into the
field of genetic engineering so uh
learning how to recode life recall uh
human cells uh record viruses so for me
sometimes i think about what do i do if
i had infinite amount of money and i'd
just be doing this
yeah i just researching because i really
enjoy this work like i want to figure
out how to
gain a mastery over the genetic code for
like viruses and for for humans
at what point
did you realize that
code 19 was gonna be a thing that we
would all have to worry about i had to
say i think i was pretty late although i
i i was concerned early so once those
videos of of people collapsing in
in the hospitals or even on the streets
once those videos started circulating
online in january i was concerned
because i had lived through the first
sars outbreak as a teenager in singapore
so for me
it wasn't like this thing that's only in
asia like i knew that these viruses
could spread pretty quickly stars one
hit singapore yes it did i didn't know
that it actually got singapore yes and
then uh yeah and i mean even reached
like canada it's just a matter of chance
so a man was a
doctor actually carried it out of china
into hong kong at the time and he he
threw up in the corridor of a hotel and
on that floor there were all these
people who you know within the week took
planes out to everywhere including
canada so
in singapore and so
all it takes is a super spreader event
um well of course when you look at the
super spreader event it's not like there
was a civic can or raccoon dog there
that infected all these people but
and that really highlights the
importance of contact tracing not just
taking for granted that there must have
been an infected animal here somewhere
but but saying okay how did the first
person
get infected you don't remember the
exact moment when you're like oh oh no
actually it's not embarrassing i
remember i was even hosting a putty
and then and then uh
amongst my my friends we were just
wondering do you think this is gonna hit
the u.s and and unbeknownst to us it had
already reached boston like there was
there was already an academic conference
here and by october 2020 it was
estimated that it was the cause of 300
000 cases just coming from that single
super spreader event where everyone's in
the conference room for two days
when did you realize that we need to
take a more serious look at the lab leak
hypothesis was there was there an
obvious moment for you no but but one of
the moments that really sticks out to me
is when i first read the proximal origin
article so proximal origin article is
this uh i'd say almost like an opinion
piece or like a
a casual analysis
of of uh the origin of covet 19. that
was written by five very distinguished
scientists uh both in the u.s australia
and then the uk
um and i remember that a friend had
shared this article with me and i said
this this can be right like maybe these
guys are not really up to date with
genetic engineering but the
assumptions they make don't rule out a
lab origin at all so just because they
wouldn't personally design a virus this
way
doesn't mean that this couldn't have
leaked from a lab by accident couldn't
have been the natural virus collected
brought to a lab grown and leaked so i
remember that moment
but it wasn't until later
when i heard news that this virus was
very genetically stable they started
bringing some alarm bells with me
because i had read a lot about the first
size virus and how as it spread from
humans to human in the first few months
of its emergence it was rapidly picking
up these new mutations that
iteratively made it better and infecting
and transmitting in humans yeah i i want
to talk more in depth about your paper
here in a minute but
the
um i actually had
maybe almost the opposite uh
story from you for
so that that paper on the proximal
origins it was it was a letter to nature
right
nature medicine that letter actually
calmed me down so i was
what happened to me is first off i of
course assumed that this is probably a
natural origin so i started making this
video about the natural origin
hypothesis
right before i published that video i
was listening to
some
some scientists talk about
conspiracy theories about the origin of
this virus i heard a top researcher
who's been in virology for a long time
and who has close ties to the lab in
wuhan i heard him get on tv and say of
course this is not a lab accident we
don't have the technology to engineer a
virus from scratch
and
i told my wife i was like
listen to this does this does this
bother you and she's like what is he
lying do we have the technology to
engineer a virus from scratch i'm like
no we don't have the general technology
to engineer a virus from scratch but
that's not what we do
we take viruses that are almost there
and we tweak them a little bit this is
worse than a lie he's telling a
half-truth and it's a half-truth that's
going to convince a lot of people yeah
it has convinced the law of people it
has so i i think that
that is extremely problematic and
especially if as we've seen more and
more documents leaking over the past
year and a half showing that there was
an unprecedented skill of engineering of
reconstituting entirely novel viruses
that they had sequenced from tens of
thousands of samples like samples
collected across eight countries not
just china but seven other southeast
asian countries were uh
in emails shown to be
potentially sending hundreds of samples
each up into ohan city so we have no
understanding of what sequences they've
found what viruses they've created what
genetic modifications they've added but
the real kicker is that there's this one
proposal called the diffuse proposal and
was submitted to dapper the defense
agency in the research agency funding
agency in the u.s
in early 2018 so about
about a year and a half more before the
pandemic started
and this proposal it said we are going
to get all these sequences of novel
viruses they're going to be
generating them in the lab like
synthetically synthesizing all these new
genomes growing these viruses in the lab
we are going to insert novel genetic
modifications like cleavage sites so
these these advantageous sites that make
viruses more infectious we're going to
put those into novel cells like viruses
and then boom
end of 2019 a novel cells like virus
with a novel cleavage site shows up in
ohan city so the analogy i like to use
for this is that there was a 2018 plan
where scientists said that i'm going to
put horns on horses
and then in 2019 a unicorn shows up in
that city so for me the the coincidence
is is striking and
i think that now the burden is on the
people on who say that this came from a
market to tell us that the research that
we're seeing reading in these
authenticated documents that this
research did not create lead to the
creation of saskov2 to be clear to our
audience my audience has probably seen
the debates between fauci and paul the
research there that rand paul was
showing
would not have led to covet 19.
what rand paul was trying to do is he's
trying to point out the fact that
there is dangerous research happening
there with sars-like viruses therefore
we need to look into this really in
depth and it was very unfortunate that
this turned into a theater and it was a
witch hunt you know like let's let's
accuse anthony fauci of being the devil
but the meat of his argument is good
it's look we have evidence that they
have been doing dangerous things there
we need to look deeper and then
afterwards this new these these new
documents were really saying that oh
actually yeah
they had proposed to add fear and
cleavage sites they'd propose to
actually mutate sarge-like viruses
in a way that could make them more
dangerous so
yes and and
uh i need to explain this to a
non-scientific audience is that often
when you see these proposals it's not
that none of the work has been done
actually quite a bit of the work might
have already been done and the reason
why a lot of scientists propose to do
work that they've already done is to
increase the chances of success so at
the end of your grant you want to be
able to go back to your funders and say
hey look i me i met like 80 of my
proposed objectives so if if you go in
there just pitching all these wild ideas
that you've never even tried out before
your success rate will be very low in
science and people will not want to keep
funding you but if you keep coming back
showing that i've i
consistently meet like you know the
majority of my goals then then it's
really good for you and this group of
scientists wasn't just chinese
scientists it was us singapore
uh china and
many of their collaborators also spend
many countries in europe and southeast
asia so this was by no means like a
like extremely taboo project to do like
it's actually very routine like anyone
who saw that idea would have been like
why don't i try that
very low cost really easy to do research
um it's not something that they should
have been embarrassed about except that
a virus with a normal cleavage site
showed up in their city so
i
i also agree with your point that
we have to be very measured with the
questions we're asking the scientists
implicated in this in this whole
like ecosystem of research so it cannot
be like you're either a saint or you're
responsible for the deaths of five
million people it can't be that there
has to be middle ground it has to be
like were you possibly blindsided by
collaborations that you didn't have
access to information that would have
shown you that they were doing risky
research so that's a very reasonable
place to be just like
how could you have possibly known
everything that was happening in the one
in steel biology like i don't even know
what's happening next door
right in the lab next door so
be reasonable when when
asking questions of scientists like they
they're not either the savior of mankind
or the person who started the pandemic
right i do want to talk about the
demonization that's happened to the
people who are now being blamed for
possibly if this was a lab accident that
they're being blamed for it
but before i do that i wanna i wanna
talk about the
accusations that have been thrown at you
it seems to me that you have been thrown
into the into the spotlight pretty
quickly you went from being a researcher
in a laboratory to being
a public figure all of a sudden
and
you know i've worked on the internet now
for 10 years and i slowly grew an
audience
and
when you have an audience on the
internet people say horrible things to
you and horrible things about you
i was able to slowly deal with that as
it
accumulated over time you got thrown
into this all of a sudden
one of the accusations that i saw thrown
at you is that you are a race trader
and
a dog whistler
people are worried that you are
promoting racism against chinese maybe
not even racism is maybe the wrong word
because there's people that are
they have issues with china the country
not the chinese people but what do you
think about the dog whistler accusation
so i think that both are made by people
who
have gotten
excessively emotional about this topic
so
to
i feel that people can get really
carried away by what they read in in the
news and so they're reading places like
the new york times like calling anyone
who who says like a lab leak is possible
like a racist or associating the lab
victory solely with trump like when
people read this they they
it can
tug at these very core emotions that
that that make them think that anyone
even just suggesting this left origin
has an agenda like it's evil it's like
this racist like anti-science like
anti-china like right winger um yeah and
it was difficult for them to put me in
that bin because one i'm not i'm not
white so
they had to change the racist part to
race trader
uh two i'm a scientist so to say that i
was anti-science like i i wasn't like
anti-gmo in fact i loved genetic
engineering
they had to even slowly shift it to a
point where but there's no people
attacking me for one not having enough
expertise or people on the other side
say that i have too much expertise
and gain of function that i'm trying to
cover up for scientists so um
there's a lot of mudslinging and i think
this has happened to a ton of scientists
a ton of public health experts like when
you tell people things that they don't
want to hear when you tell people things
that they have heard associated with
people they hate
like
these these personal attacks and threats
and these things
they will show up so
i
i'm not going to say it's easy it was
obviously very bad and distressing at
one point there were lots of like phone
calls and emails and stuff coming in and
and going to my workplace and i think
that's the worst because there's a human
being there on the other end receiving
all these really awful
mostly misinformed and mistaken like
uh
abuses so
um
but i think that fixating too much on
that on on
on the fact that there are some pretty
irate people on on the internet and but
possibly some some very violent
individuals uh
it can be very distracting from this
topic which requires a response like a
actionable response so i i feel that all
this talking about personal stories
i understand the interest
but it also takes oxygen away from this
like issue
that
till today there's no credible
investigation there's zero measures
taken to prevent a future pandemic
whether natural or lab and there's like
no pandemic response like you see when
the old micron or the omicron when it
when it appeared
some countries responded as if they
never lived through this pandemic they
still kept all these passengers on the
plane together breathing air together
without mask on while testing them for
like you know overnight so
i feel that there have been
almost no lessons learned
yeah
yeah on this the issue of these
accusations against you
we know that the the lab leak message is
being exploited by people who have
issues with china and by by hate groups
and so on
and you are actually
in a
a spot where it's it's easy for you to
be used in this because
because you have chinese ancestry right
yeah yeah people can use you to say the
things that they're no longer
comfortable saying because i'm sure
there's people watching this
conversation right now who might be
really trying to figure out what my
motives are am i inviting you on here
because i actually just secretly hate
china and i'm trying to um
make a video about that without saying
it myself yeah and i think it sometimes
disappoints people when i counter that
this is not actually a china problem
this is a international problem it's
that this type of research uh
and actually even the wildlife trade
it's not a china only problem like it's
it's everywhere and like
you know people here in the u.s out
there hunting down bald animals and then
trading their beds and birds and you
know like especially birds and things
like that like you know just like
there's all these people who
um
regardless of race or culture are
engaging in activities whether it's
research or wildlife trade or hunting
that
we we need to bring them together and
say like okay maybe maybe this stuff is
not worth a pandemic like even the
research like i know that you
i know that you know you want to prevent
the pandemic and stuff but if this
actually causes pandemics maybe you
should slow down like no matter which
country you're at and then figure out
new global standards new new practices
new recommendations and prohibitions
let's talk about your your research so
the first paper that you published it
didn't get picked up by a journal did it
so we submitted it to a few journals but
they didn't even want to send it for
peer review at the time i was pretty
naive like i thought
maybe we didn't cite enough papers from
that family of journals that kind of
thing like i was just really puzzled by
why it wasn't even sent for peer review
and then our paper got our preprint good
uh thrown into the tabloid circulation
and then i realized that it was
extremely political but it was just a
single line if you read the preprint
itself it's very careful and it's very
long
it lists all of these limitations and
caveats of our analysis we're very
careful um
and there's only a single line in there
that says that
you know there are all these different
origin scenarios including wildlife
trade uh pre-circulation in humans so
maybe it was in a village somewhere
circulating for more than a year and
then it just emerged in one or maybe it
was from a lab accident so that single
line that got us into so much hot water
let's be really clear about about what
you published so what you found is that
when sars one broke out it broke into
the human population spilled over from
animals
and it started to evolve quite rapidly
at the start
before it settled into a more stable
phase and what we know from evolutionary
biology is that that's because it was
adapting to its new host
and it took a while for it to find a
sweet spot to where it could really take
off and once it found that sweet spot it
was under selection pressure to stay
that way more or less it was working
so it stabilized
with stars cov2 when it immediately
broke out it was already
genetically stable which tells us that
it was somehow pre-adapted
to survive and spread in humans you guys
looked at this data you compared and
really you were only comparing two
viruses in that paper you compared stars
cov1 to the the new one
so i think maybe people could criticize
it wasn't enough sample size look at
look at all the other viruses that have
broken spilled over a lot of them might
be stable too
but the
the conclusion you came to is that it
was somehow pre-adapted to infect humans
and you gave three scenarios one was
that it had pre-adapted an animal
somehow one was that maybe it had
pre-adapted into cell culture in a
laboratory and one was that maybe it had
broken into the human population far
earlier than we thought those are three
completely reasonable hypothesis
and
it really amazes me that that caused
drama
yeah why was this question so dangerous
why was it so taboo just to ask how did
this virus adapt for human transmission
and infection and even as you you follow
the literature the research literature
for months into like even mid or late
2020 scientists can only say that within
that period the only adaptive mutation
they could find is a single mutation in
the spike called the d614g mutation um
and actually a
a journalist a science journalist
confronted me later saying that my idea
wasn't normal because many other
scientists including the proximal origin
artist had said that this virus was
pre-adapted
for human transmission and even the
whole the world health organization and
their joint report of china said that
this virus was clearly well adapted to
humans and there's several more and so
over the past year and a half as we've
seen this virus break into new animal
populations from jumping from humans to
mink or deer we've seen
several independent analysis come out
saying that they are seeing rapid
adaptation of this virus when it jumps
into mink so i still
am quite convinced by the available data
and and
evidence and analysis that this virus
was very
very infectious very um
it had reached this point where it
wasn't rapidly picking up all these
mutations anymore and we have no sign of
an animal host like zero signs of any
pre-circulation in human populations we
don't know how this virus that's so good
infecting people just suddenly appeared
in the horn city and that for me is a
critical question to how did this virus
originate let's explore for a minute
though how it could have happened if
this was a natural origin that jumped
over either to people who were in a cave
or maybe bats that were roosting in
their house one of the kind of weird
things about this disease is that so
many people have
no symptoms at all
so
i mean
this virus is unusual and that it could
actually pass undetected for quite a
while within a population you know my my
wife is a nurse and we have we have
people i'm i'm in canada we have people
that will die of strange diseases you
have to have several cases in a row
before anyone even notices that there
might be a new thing that's happening in
the community because doctors don't talk
to each other all the time they don't
always share their cases with each other
people just don't notice
when there's a new
disease that's killing people and
especially in rural china when you've
got
a lot of people probably don't go to the
doctor at all when they're sick in in
some of these areas
is it possible that you could have
actually just had
sustained human transmission for months
or even longer is it possible that this
could have been slowly circulating for
years absolutely so i think it's
possible and and that's why it's
shocking to me that china has waited
this long to test banked blood samples
because one way to tell if this virus
was pre-circulating in uhan or other
cities in china is to test all the blood
samples for antibodies for
susceptibility to or even if you have
patient samples from people who uh had
pneumonia or flu like flu-like symptoms
a lot of these were being collected by
hospitals in uhan as well as around
china so like no like sputum so like
spit samples or even like you know
samples like there are many ways they
could have checked but they didn't they
just waited until like just like
recently just a few weeks ago and then
they told the wh show okay but go look
for it so
for me when i hear that
and this is
this this virus is a problem for the
whole world but actually
the biggest problem it poses is to china
because this is where the virus emerged
like when it was first detected so for a
country of this size
to to not know where a killer virus
emerged it's very
it's a very large national security risk
so it's in their best interest to
quickly and definitively find the source
of this new dangerous pathogen but
you're telling me that they waited two
years before testing all these patient
samples that they destroyed early
samples like
it strains credibility so like i
i
yeah we have not found any animal house
we haven't found any signs of
pre-circulation and that's why
i feel that the circumstantial evidence
is leaning quite strongly towards a lab
origin when i was reading your book one
of the things that struck me is that
each piece of evidence everything is
circumstantial
so there's no there's no direct evidence
of of a lab leak that we have access to
the public has access to scientists are
all doing this mostly from their home
countries and they're trying to
investigate from afar it's we're
extremely limited and every piece of
evidence on its own can be dismissed and
it actually can be dismissed fairly
easily but it's
it's when you take it all in together
that you're like okay this
it looks like there's a sign here yeah
it's pointing somewhere there's so much
smoke that it looks like there it looks
like there's a fire here
there's a whole bunch of
independent lines of evidence suggesting
independent lines of circumstantial
evidence
but independent lines nonetheless that
are all pointing towards the same thing
the claim that you have been making
isn't that these researchers did it your
claim is they there needs to be an
investigation yes and that is the most
reasonable request
i could think of
it's been kind of
ludicrous watching the the shift
on the side of the natural origins since
early 2020 to now so they began by
saying that
a leak hypothesis is a conspiracy theory
they say it was racist it was
anti-chinese it was right-wing
conspiracy uh they said no lab-based
scenarios were plausible they said we
can rule it out now anyone suggesting
this is anti-signs and then they moved
to we never said that they said yeah of
course it's possible and then they move
from of course it's possible to of
course it's plausible and in fact we
were the ones who said that we should
investigate the lab like i'm like um can
you go back to your tweets from early
2020 and check yourselves and now we are
hearing them say that oh these live
leakers they're just out there to get
money
and you're like oh my god it's just like
can can you follow your own like writing
since like early 2020 to now and you
have any self introspection here that
then maybe you were wrong and just just
admit it so we can all move forward
together like i i don't have any
judgment for you let's just get things
solved like solve this problem like i
don't care what you say about me i don't
know if you saw this recent it was in
sciencescience.org
it was a
an interview with peter desak
the prophet in purgatory yes
yes
it was the first time that i've heard
him say that of course it's possible
things have happened in the past when
he's talking about a lab leak he's
talking about uh a spillover with
someone who is collecting
yeah
samples yeah you are not
spiteful in the book
but when i'm reading the book and when
when when you start to see all the
things that that peter has done
it starts to get really easy to hate him
and to think that he's he's hiding
things and when i get online and i i
read what people are writing about him
he is demonized xi jung li is demonized
it's horrible things that people are
saying about them
how do you feel about this like what's
what's happening to these people that
are stuck on the other side of this of
this debate i'm a highly empathetic
individual so like i i always try to put
myself in the shoes of people who even i
i dislike and trying to figure out like
what what is it like to be them like
could they have made better decisions
if they could have made better decisions
what what are those decisions so
they they were put in very
challenging situations so like you know
uh
when saskov2 was detected when this
genome was published was was released on
january 10 or 11 like 2020
their collaborators the collaborators of
these uhan scientists would have known
that they were working with several of
the closest virus relative to this virus
in the lab that they were synthesizing
new cells like viruses making these
unique genetic modifications to them
that they were even starting to do work
with mers human pathogens in this lab
like they knew that there was this like
excessive activity research activity
pulling in tens of thousands of samples
from across china and seven southeast
asian countries into uhan so what do you
do in that situation
and i think the adult thing to do would
have been
saying
look
accidents happen to even the best of us
let's
handle this calmly we'll investigate in
a timely and transparent manner but
everyone should take note that yes this
could be a lab accident and
just respond accordingly
but instead they went with the complete
opposite route they said that a live
accident is a conspiracy theory
yeah i mean that's completely crazy
because like life accidents happen a lot
like even within the u.s
in 2019 per week there were at least
four exposures
on average of select agents so the most
dangerous of the dangerous pathogens and
then toxins per week in the us at least
four on average so
a lab leak is not a conspiracy it's a
real risk and for for these top
scientists to put their names to a
prominent letter condemning anyone
suggesting a lab origin of cover 19 i
think they dug a really deep hole for
themselves like that's very hard for
them to climb out of now today
they did so
as a science community or someone who
who loves science and
like that enraged me when i saw that i
was so angry and i i didn't say anything
publicly about it at the time because i
needed to calm down
having said that though i started trying
to think why are they doing this because
obviously it's absurd it's just
obviously absurd i knew from the
research that i've been doing that there
was this laboratory and wuhan and they
were studying coronaviruses it was super
obvious that this is a possibility a
loud leak is a possibility
and
the only thing that i could think of
because i'm trying to give them the
benefit of the doubt
is that
they were in emergency mode they
couldn't they
contact was severed between them and
their chinese collaborators and we have
a pandemic what matters more than
the reputation of scientists what
matters more than anything is being able
to get in contact with our collaborators
and make sure that we can figure out
what happened we need access to
information and if china shut down
because china thinks that we're now
blaming them for everything we have to
do whatever it takes to open up those
those uh communication channels again so
that that's
that's the thing that i can think of
that justifies what they did i mean from
my perspective it doesn't even justify
it because i care what i care most about
is scientific integrity but the i could
see you making a calculation like look
we're gonna we're gonna do something
messed up
but it's for the greater good so that we
can contact our researchers there and
figure out what really happened because
we don't know
i think that's a good hypothesis but the
evidence doesn't seem to point there so
if you look at all these emails that
have been obtained through the freedom
of information act
we find that peter deshak the president
of the equal health alliance that was a
long long-time funder and collaborators
of the ukhon institute of biology he had
written this letter he had written the
first draft and then when he went around
getting signatures he told people don't
don't put your equal health alliance
affiliation here let's make it look like
it's coming from a lot of independent
scientists and then when one scientist
pushed back slightly just saying
whatever what evidence do you have for
natural origin he's like oh this and
that like
he said let's not get too specific in
here let's let's just condemn them all
as conspiracy theories so like
there is no evidence of them saying this
is how they will keep the channel open
with china if if i had seen that then
sure like okay great like i understand
why you did that but we don't see any of
that in fact
even more emails came out saying that a
few of them had a phone call saying
isn't this acting in our self-interest
and they said oh yeah maybe we all
shouldn't put our names on them because
they look like self-interested and
defeat the purpose of this and then
i'm just like this this is almost like a
circus that's happening in there like
they were definitely in panic mode
in emergency panic mode
but i
i
i don't think that it was completely
noble
i i really want to be able to give
people a way out because i feel like
we're trapping people
in a corner
and i mean china right now is the the
chinese government right now is
definitely backed into a corner like the
the time for them to
if this was a lab leak the time for them
to admit that and ask for forgiveness
like
i hope that's still possible but it
seems like it's
less and less possible
it is still open
and
honestly it's better for them to tell us
now than to wait for an actual
investigation to happen and then have
the evidence really pressed to them
because i believe that this evidence
does exist and it's just for the lack of
a credible systematic international
investigation that hasn't been put
together because china is not a black
box and we live in the 21st century in
the early days of the pandemic even in
the years and months leading up to
pandemic there must have been tens of
thousands if not hundreds of thousands
of messages like data records being
shared outside of china maybe not to the
us but to collaborators and who knows
like australia singapore like other
southeast asian countries so
if china decides to let this drag on
another five years of investigation
finally putting together a very full
picture of a potential lab origin or
even a wildlife origin if there's some
signs of them showing cover-up of a
wildlife origin of this it looks worse
than to just just get this over with now
just
so everyone can move on together like
it's clear now that it's not the china
only problem they saw the research was a
product of international a global
consortia so
if there's blame to go around it's not
just china
that being said that's just about the
lab accident
there's a different situation here where
a lot of cover-up happened like yeah
human to human transmission data not
shared transmission before symptoms show
up not shared so these these are
separate category of issues different
from the origin of covet 19. the same
time that i published that first video i
wrote about the lab origin hypothesis
so it was again this is back in february
and
i was
what i pointed out in that article is
that
this could have happened anywhere the
fact that this
the fact that this might have happened
in china is a coincidence i mean it's
we do this same type of research in i
think it's north carolina right
yes and the research is ongoing so now
instead of
sending samples to uhan they're sending
samples to boston and to north carolina
so
we do it in new york city we did there's
there's a lab right right next to
central park and we do it in atlanta
georgia
next to the biggest international
airport we do research on this this is a
problem we can easily rectify which is
to to
centralize all of this dangerous
pathogen research in a luxury island
somewhere where all the scientists
around the world can apply for grants
and permissions to to bring their work
there and have the best time of their
lives investigating these pathogens but
have a very good quarantine and like
surveillance protocol in this island so
instead of having a situation now where
we have dozens of these pathogen labs
just separated all across the world in
different countries there's no
transparency no idea no surveillance and
we're just sitting ducks we're just
waiting for that outbreak to happen and
then for the whole world to pay the
consequence and so
i'm just looking at this current
pandemic and we don't even know whether
it's from nature from a lab but what is
clear to us is that this this virus is
here to stay there's no eradication
route i can see like it's already in
animals like even if you fully vaccinate
the entire human population
there will always be new variants coming
back through true animals to us so we
can't afford to keep building up this
repertoire of
vaccines we need to take on a regular
basis like what's gonna happen to our
kids are they gonna take like 12
vaccines per month like for different
pathogens that have taken over the world
oh my gosh and yeah and
you know these vaccines are amazing
but it also really sucks to get them
because
for me it knocks me out for like a day
yeah
so
it's yeah imagine if
i i i worry a lot about what kind of
advertising coven 19 was for
military groups and even terrorist
groups
yeah
do you have a sense of how many
laboratories like military laboratories
there might be that are experimenting
with viruses aside from the the public
ones that we we sort of know where most
of them are do you have any idea how
extensive this is
i'd say that i'm more worried about
accidents and well-intentioned labs than
military labs because they're military
labs like um
they do a lot of dual use research so
things that have civilian
use and also military use
but these tend to be very few
uh
and
i'm more worried about the thousands of
researchers and students and trainees
who are out there doing random projects
and sometimes there's very little
oversight like these safety protocols
and like
there's some labs where the professor
doesn't even know what's happening in
that lab
and now now we are there was a recent
announcement from the u.s cdc
saying that um hey guys like we've
decided now that if you're making
chimera of sas one and size two where
you're putting virulence factors so
things that cause
pathogen like characteristics from size
1 into size 2. uh that's pretty
dangerous and you should tell us so that
we can give you proper approval and if
you want to keep working with it just
let us know i'm like no
that means a lot of people are doing it
yeah i mean like if the government came
out and made a rule about it that means
that lots of people are doing it yeah
they've heard at least one or two people
doing it but i'm just like why is this
work happening how can there be so
little oversight like
just there's no need to make a sauce one
size to baby like this
there's no i can see close to zero like
benefit to doing this and then but
instead and massive risk like we're
freaking out over the omicron just for
like you know 50 mutations in there
if you put the cells one
like dangerous bit into your size too
it's just we have no idea what that
pandemic will look like and we've seen
how infectious these viruses are like
it's just even from a bsl tree even a
double vaccinated person can catch this
virus like yeah
there's no need to do this
i want to address
conspiracy theories and internet sleuths
because you guys talk about this a lot
in your book the
the the value of like random people on
the internet looking into stuff and
there's a really funny comic that was
it's been circulating since the pandemic
started
of this guy like in his underwear on his
computer and he says honey look i i
discovered something that all the world
scientists have missed it's funny
because
i published this video on youtube about
the origin of covid and immediately i i
i got thousands of emails about people's
ideas
and most of them are absolutely absurd
i've gotten a lot dude
or sorry youtube comments i got
thousands of youtube comments i got tens
of emails
i wrote down this short list this was
probably the first month after i had
published my video these were the
theories people sent me some said it was
communist it was trump it was democrats
it was the chinese it was bill gates it
was the koreans it was the jews it was
the georgians it was elitists it was
republicans it was allah it was aliens
it was 5g
it was god it was satanists
it was satan it was melted glaciers it
was the one percenters it was big pharma
i mean i'm just
saying what their the conclusion was but
people are sending these things with
absolute certainty that they know that
this was 5g or they know that this was
the republicans and
they would always have some sort of uh
thing that they found online that they
would send me as evidence for this and
so it's really easy for us to dismiss
when when this is the atmosphere
people with absolute certainty that they
know what the what no one else knows
it's really easy to dismiss the value in
these random people on the internet that
are looking into things but
what we found is that
these people you know maybe a million of
them come up with some
[ __ ] idea
but every once in a while someone
actually finds something extremely
important and so i want to i want to
talk to you about
what i found most interesting was people
who were reading masters theses and phd
theses that were written in chinese
that's something that no scientist would
do right
well i mean i didn't
um
amongst these internet sloops they're
actually quite a few scientists
and
that's even a paris group it's a group
of uh
scientists international but started by
uh scientists in paris uh in france that
have now
started to meet on a monthly basis at
least to talk about these origin issues
so there's almost like underground
although they're very transparent in
public a modern um
group of people who who are really
determined to evaluate all the evidence
whether it's deemed uh you know up to
scientific standard or not like they
want to look at it the parish group this
is the people who signed that the letter
oh wall street journal wall street
journal yeah yes
okay yeah the paris group and they wrote
three more and they they published them
online too
i'll say this like you know do i do i
wish that this problem had been solved
by scientists by top scientists yes i
wish that had happened i wish that top
prominent scientists in the field of
virology had stepped up on day one and
said it could have come from a lab let's
look at this transparently i wish that
that happened but that didn't happen in
fact prominent virologists say it was a
conspiracy theory so they created this
vacuum this this role for outsiders to
fill outsiders like me so
a lot of people say that i am not a
virologist especially i have very strong
expertise in
handling viruses and genetic engineering
so i am an outsider but i have the
expertise to evaluate all these evidence
yeah so um
this this
this vacuum no one
none of these people who should be doing
the job their job of tracking origins of
evaluating whether this virus might come
from a lab
had to be filled by by
junior people like me outsiders like
people who are willing to sacrifice a
lot like there are a few brave
virologists who have stepped up and said
yeah this this looks like it came from a
lab or we have to investigate so
and amongst that group it was
it began mostly with these internet
sleuths again some of whom have
scientific degrees so they weren't
satisfied with the story that was being
floated in the media they weren't
satisfied with just throwing lab origin
of the table
they went out to gather as much
information as they could and one of
them called the seeker who we described
in the book he found an online login to
the chinese thesis database so in in
china there's this national database
where all the medical academic thesis
research thesis are posted in that
database
and he pulled out two thesis
showing um
one of them even was from the lab of the
chinese cdc director so these are legit
labs
legit research groups talking about
these these cases of miners uh six
miners who in 2012 second with a
sars-like
disease like almost a corvette-like
disease but but not the same
and this batch of cases drew so much
attention from top chinese groups
including the uh institute of virology
that they all kept repeatedly visiting
the mine where these people had worked
collecting virus bad sample
to bring back to their labs and from
that lab from that mind the uhan
institute of virology found the nine
closest relatives to size two at the
time that it emerged and so
this we we talk a lot about the story
and we express our surprise by how when
saskatchewan emerged none of this
information was shared so the ohana
steve biology didn't tell us actually
we've been working with nine of his
closest relatives and they all come from
this mind of death
where six minus got ill with a covert
like illness we thought it was and half
of them died so imagine that the world
had gotten that information on day one
it might have reshaped this pandemic
entirely like yes we would have
we would have experienced more fear more
concern by like uh yeah this came from a
place where how the people died
so maybe let's like take this more
seriously instead we would so don't
worry it's not transmitting amongst
humans like it's it's just jumping from
animals in the market again i think that
really was damaging to the pandemic
response this part of your book
revealing that story
that was what i thought was the second
most useful part of your book the most
impressive part of your book to me was
just the the history of lab leaks in in
the past i had no idea how
how extensive how many and for anyone
who's thinking about whether or not they
should look at this book i would
recommend buying it just for that that
history but this
this
i heard about the people who got sick in
this cave like in the news somehow i did
not know
that this
resulted from some guy on the internet
sneaking around and reading lots of
stuff i thought that it came i thought
that china had just volunteered that
information i didn't know that this was
forced out of them and
this is
this really is an example of some guy
saying honey look what i found that all
the scientists missed on the internet
this actually happened this guy found
this thesis
that
you know for people who outside of
science maybe they don't know how this
works but when you're trying to get your
master's degree or your phd you write a
big long report about something that you
did your research on
and
usually nobody reads it except for
not not even your parents yeah your
parents don't even read it it's long and
it's boring and it's tedious and someone
has to read it to make sure that you get
your phd or not but other than that
it just it gets saved and it gets
publicly saved usually
so one of the things that these internet
sleuths were doing is they were just
reading them they were reading all of
these long boring papers and they found
this one
that revealed that china knew that six
people had died china researchers knew
that six people had died in this country
six infected tree dead yes
yes six infected three dead of a
sars-like virus may be a fungal like
there was there was debate about it
being a fungus versus a virus right and
that nobody brought this up like that is
an amazing find i can't believe that
came from
a dude on the internet versus
being volunteered by these researchers
who are concerned about where the heck
this virus originated
yeah i mean so let's think about that
again right so you have these chinese
researchers who cannot reveal things uh
because of political pressure because of
like serious life or death situations so
i almost have no judgement for them like
i don't know what i would do in their
position
but what about the collaborators right
so
what about scientists outside of china
they should have done more due diligence
and instead it was left to internet
sleuths so the book really gets into the
story of several of these who who just
like were extremely persistent like they
didn't care about all the names they
were being called online and sure they
got lots of stuff wrong but they also
achieved a lot of things that shouldn't
have been done by top scientists but
weren't being done by top scientists and
honestly i i don't know if i would have
been drawn into this so much as as the
fact that a journalist reached out to me
in in june saying that hey did you
notice that under your tweets someone
has posted this medical thesis like do
you want to read it and see what it says
and so
at the time i was like locked down at
home i was like okay i'll take a look at
this thesis um then it was in chinese
which i
can read to some extent with the help of
google translate but sometimes i'm
better than google translate and within
the day i had translated this medical
thesis and it was
i was really
um
distressed by it like i was just so
horrified by the stuff that wasn't being
told to the world about this this this
set of cases with like covet like
symptoms medical thesis says
they they're pretty confident this came
from a stars like virus from bats in
this cave as like shouldn't the whole
world know about this right now so that
we can take this seriously because this
was back in like june there's still a
time when people thought this might just
disappear like
like when scientists who thought that
the pandemic would end by the end of
2020 they were like do we need to still
keep thinking about this like isn't this
gonna be gone in 2021 and here we are
today so like
um
i
i think that people underestimate the
power of
of information like for me in a single
day receiving all this information from
this thesis of just like painstakingly
translating it
i was
like following the cases especially when
you when you watch all these patients
struggling for their lives in the
hospital for for weeks like one guy was
in there for like 120 days in the
hospital like they weren't sure people
from the from the thesis from the mine
yeah
so like he
you weren't sure if they were gonna live
and then by by luck they had given this
person an anti-coagulant
so an anti-clotting like a molecule a
heparin and and he recovered
miraculously so
when i when i was reading this you
really just get drawn into this
situation that you have this
you know mysterious six cases they're
fighting for their lives in there they
called in the top uh chinese like sars
expert like some people have said he's
the the anthony fauci of china they
called in this guy called dr chong
nanchan and he said go to that cave
immediately take samples from the beds
send the patient samples for tsar's
testing
and the two thesis that were found by
the seeker one of them the medical
thesis said the wiv the uhan institute
biology found virus antibodies in the
and then the thesis from the chinese cdc
director's lab said we found uh
antibodies for sars virus in these minus
blood samples so when you're reading
this thesis you just are really
just shocked by this revelation
nobody was told about this
when sus two emerged in wuhan this group
is called they call themselves drastic
brett weinstein calls himself the dark
horse
and it's these sound like band names
that you would have in high school or
like um
i don't know
some people buy a motorcycle during
their midlife crisis some people call
themselves the dark horse like
it seems
it's easy to dismiss people
that are like internet slus and that
that have these code names for
themselves but the proof is right here
these people are not
just
weirdos on the internet they're doing
real work and there's a bunch of misses
i think to every hit that you have where
they actually did something good there's
probably a million false leads that
you've you've been sent i'm sure
the vast majority of information that
comes to us is bogus
but this is this is the
the power of crowdsourcing is that if
you get enough people no matter what
their motives are if you get enough
people poking around they're going to
find something we can't dismiss
these outside channels
yeah so i think that there's a role to
play for independent analysts as well as
a credible like investigation team so
yeah there's there's only so much that
internet investigators can do like
amtrak detectives they like
they don't like to be called internet
loops and things like that but that
that's what that's what people are when
you're searching for stuff on internet
like i consider myself also an internet
sleuth because i was searching a lot of
stuff online um but
we really need a systematic
investigation we need
authority we need someone who can
ask for emails to be shared privately uh
so i think there's a lot more that needs
to be investigated a lot of this
information communication data rackets
they sit
in new york city and
equal health alliance with
where we've seen that they might be
sitting on like a treasure trove of
information they could tell us about the
type of science like research that was
happening in uhan i think something else
worth mentioning here too is that
the the scientific process just the
culture that's developed in science a
huge trail that we leave when we're
doing research you've got all these
students that are writing
um these uh they'll write a thesis for
their phd and so on
everything is is published not
everything is published but lots of
things are published and there's there's
this incentive to publish as much as you
possibly can and so there's a bunch of
clues that are hidden in published data
and it's hidden in plain sight but you
have to have someone who sits down and
goes through it this is where this
crowdsourcing getting everyone on the
internet excited to go read through this
stuff is really helpful because we need
as many eyes on this as we can there's
way more data than there are our eyes to
look at it you know
yes and i also wanted at this point that
a lot of these
research thesis they describe work that
was done years ago so there's
unfortunately there's no way we're gonna
see the work that was happening in 2018
and 2019 because they haven't been
written into thesis yet they haven't
been defended and at this rate they will
not be put online anymore uh so uh
for that most up-to-date information on
like what viruses were found and things
like that unfortunately we have to go
knock on the doors of the collaborators
the funders and say like so did you have
any reports from 2018 or 2019 and we've
seen from that diffuse proposal that
they were going in a pretty dangerous
direction that they were saying i'm
gonna start putting in these novel
genetic features into novel
size like viruses and see what happens
so we we need to be getting more insight
into those types of documents
is it possible for
a single virus to actually cause the
extinction of the human species
is that possible i wouldn't say
extinction because there's so many of us
now that they're bound to be people who
are not that susceptible to some viruses
no matter how little it is to some other
people uh
but i'd say that it it might cause the
collapse or uh regression of
civilization so we're quite used to
seeing these apocalypse or like
contagion movies
i think these are possible but
it's difficult to predict right so we
don't know what types of viruses are out
there we don't know what types of
viruses could be engineered
there's this whole contentious area of
risky pathogen research that hit a
boiling point in
2011
when two separate groups of scientists
made a bird flu
airborne between mammals so something
that could pass through the air
presumably amongst humans with a 60
mortality rate in humans h5n1 right
i have to double check
yeah
that was the one with yeah the 60
mortality rate which is is worse than
thanos for people listening thanos only
killed half the world's population in
the avengers movies this virus would
kill
uh
you know 60 of the people who get it
yeah so we described this at length in
the book and
imagine that that was unleashed
on in the world and imagine if this
virus could
infect people and spread before you
start showing symptoms that would be a
disaster because like that that is that
is the key criteria that really makes
south korea 2 what it is is that
you don't know when you're a carrier
isn't isn't that crazy that half of the
transmissions uh
have been coming from people who had
mild or no symptoms they didn't even
know they were giving it to like
hundreds of people in the same room so
imagine if you could do that with a
virus that kills 60 of people so
some people say like what's the chances
of that virus happening i don't know
like what happens if there's a crazy
lamb out there that decides to do that
like what happens if there's a lamb on
that that's putting sauce one more rule
inspectors and disaster were like
backbones and then out pops this
dangerous virus that kills 10 of the
people but can spread pretty
symptomatically so we don't want to be
playing with those like we don't want to
create the monster that we are trying to
guard against um
and so
for me it's it's urgent and important
that uh scientists internationally
convene at a neutral location and set
new ground rules for everyone and set in
new structural changes in the research
community and the research publication
community so that we got against these
reckless behaviors
so you don't feel that this is an
existential threat to our species you
feel that it but it could be an
existential threat to modern society yes
i mean no one wants to live in like the
zombie apocalypse right so even without
zombies like having to scavenge through
like leftover canned food and eat like
dog food that kind of thing like we
don't want to regress
we could lose our technology and
everything we yeah we have seen this
happen with civilizations i think it was
the
i think it was new zealand the natives
there
sorry maybe it's tasmania i'm thinking
of tasmania had lost all the technology
that they they'd come from
australia must have been they had lost
all their technology that they had in
australia
and
like they couldn't even use fire anymore
because their population went through a
huge
bottleneck so that they lost their
technology without going extinct
it would be catastrophic if you see more
than half the people around you dying i
promise you there will be no more law
and order okay yeah oh yeah yeah it'll
be like walking dead without the zombies
but
as we know the most terrifying things
are not the zombies but other people
when when civilization collapses yeah
and we saw this with the black plague i
mean everybody was accusing everybody
else there was witchcraft
and there is a there is a huge slaughter
of
jewish people during the black plague i
mean the black plague happened multiple
times but
the
it it's absolute chaos when this happens
when you when you get a really and we're
seeing it right now with um
just with just with this fairly mild
disease we're seeing hatred increase
we're seeing violence increase and so on
it's
things are so fragile so so fragile we
really have to make sure that this does
not happen
and that it especially that it doesn't
happen from a lab i did a video on gain
and function research months ago
and i i kind of proposed a solution
similar to what yours was like we need
to have a place where every worker in
the lab is quarantined before they go
home
i don't i don't understand why we have
these labs
in cities with international airports
that seems absurd to me
or just smack in the middle but yeah
just someone could walk out the door
like just with a pathogen and they don't
know and soon enough like half the city
is infected so
um
if you move these out of
densely populated cities if you increase
surveillance and quarantine measures
around these dangerous labs you're
you're dramatically reducing the chances
of a pandemic igniting and just getting
out of control
i think the mindset here
which i've heard from a lot of top
virologists is that they believe mother
nature is the best bio terrorist they're
like we don't need to make any bioterror
in the lab because the mother nature is
already producing lots of them but i'm
like no actually you are creating new
bioterror in the lab too and and we're
getting to a point where where people
the technology is so good that you can
definitely make pretty dangerous viruses
in the lab so
i'm not super worried about malicious
actors for now because there's no way to
gut against the virus yourself once it's
been leaked uh i'm more worried about
accidents so scientists who have the
best intentions but no one goes to work
thinking today i'm gonna have a scratch
or i'm gonna breathe in some inhale some
virus and then a pandemic will start and
i my experiment will kill five million
people no one can go to work under that
kind of emotional burden so everyone
keeps thinking if an accident happens it
happens to somebody else and some other
sloppy country and some other sloppy lab
with some sloppy biosafety practices but
we've seen time and again it happens to
the best people at the best labs in the
best countries so the best tech and the
best biosecurity
levels like accidents happen to
everybody and so i think we really need
to drill that mentality home is that
this is not this is not mother nature is
always going to make something worse
than us no we're way past that stage now
we're bringing those things into our
cities we're making them worse by
accident and we could
we could be starting pandemics and just
just as a reminder people who follow my
stuff already know about this but the
the cd the uscdc accidentally sent
h5n1
to a chicken lab in
in georgia the highest biosecurity
research lab in the world accidentally
sent one of the deadliest viruses you
could possibly send completely by
accident
stuff happens just think about how easy
it is to accidentally spill something
yeah or
we have these viruses in animals how
hard is it to catch a mouse when it runs
away you know
like it's not easy to catch a mouse
that's it's escaped
it's so easy for something to happen
even when we have every
security in place
and we're playing with fire here this is
very very
dangerous we need to take this
seriously even if it turns out that this
was a natural origin i think that this
is just a wake-up call for us to look at
this and re-evaluate this
you have said that you think it's really
important that we actually find
for sure the origin of this
what if we just don't and we just
assume that it might have been a lab and
it might have been nature isn't that
enough for us to
kick into gear and fix these problems
anyways
it's very difficult for society to
function when there are two halves of it
believing in different truths right
we're even seeing that with democracy
like how do you function when half the
country thinks a vote was stolen whereas
the other half doesn't think of stone
like we can't we have to like trace the
facts we have to build a proper
investigation like a proper picture of
what might have happened so uh there are
three reasons why finding origin is so
important and one of it is to
be able to know how to prevent against
lab leaks so unless you know exactly how
this happened like details how could you
prevent this from happening again so
yeah and the second one is about setting
a precedent so showing countries that we
will investigate you
normal pathogens emerge on the doorsteps
of your bio safety labs if you keep
showing people no we can't do it because
we're afraid of being racist or being
seen as racist then then all the all the
non-white countries get a free pass then
they'll be like oh another thing
appeared in like i don't know one of the
asian countries we can't investigate
because it would be racist to do so
that's crazy then then you're not
disincentivizing uh reckless behavior
one of the things that linfa wong said
he's upset he's saying that america is
not following their innocent until
proven guilty mantra
and
i understand that we need to assume
innocence until proven guilty but that
doesn't mean we
don't investigate he basically he's
asking us not to investigate this that's
what it seems like he's he's suggesting
he's upset that people are suspecting
that this might have happened
you know i'm i'm happily married
everyone
who knows my wife and i know that we're
happily married but if my wife had been
murdered and nobody knew who did it i
would be the prime suspect and i would
be investigated for that because we have
to investigate as uncomfortable and
horrible as it is you know we do this in
america when when a husband is grieving
for the loss of his wife
we investigate him and make sure it
wasn't him and it's brutal for that
person who's grieving a loss
and also being accused it's brutal it
really is brutal it's horrible
we have to investigate this possibility
of course it's possible that this was a
lab leak
it's absurd not to want to investigate
this
yeah and so i think that turning this
into a political game saying that
uh maybe we shouldn't find out so that
we can maintain good trade relations
that is terrifying because you're
telling people that as long as you're a
powerful country will let you off the
hook so okay all these powerful
countries just going crazy with dual use
pathogen research and no one can ever
hold them accountable or ask for
transparency because they're afraid of
hurting trade relations like
it it just sets a bad precedent uh and
like how many lives is enough like
what's the threshold like how deadly
does this pandemic need to be before we
can have an investigation it's like 15
million lives not sufficient like
and do we need to like
increase that to a billion before it's
worth investigating when civilization
has completely collapsed that's when we
will investigate so i think this is such
an important precedent setting moment it
is final question here it would be
interesting to to learn how you think
like internationally we could heal from
this but i think that neither you nor i
are experts in this like like yeah i
have no idea what the consequences would
be if this does get blamed on china i
have no idea
even you just mentioned a trade war you
said it's not worth it it's not worth
risking a trade war some people have
said that some some people have said
that yeah
but i honestly honestly i don't i don't
know how brutal a trade war would be i
mean a trade war would probably end up
in resulting lots of deaths as well
right because
our whole economy i just don't know
but how do we move forward in the
scientific community how do we heal from
this because there is major division
happening there are scientists that i
really respect and love you know the
twiv which is uh this week in virology
it's this podcast there's these amazing
virologists that are on there and i get
some
so much good information from listening
to that but they have gone hardcore like
anti-lab league they weren't in the
start at the start um they actually
helped me consider it more
they they're like oh man i sure hope
that that didn't come from a lab that
would be horrible it was a comment that
they had made early on now when i go and
listen to their
comments about a lab leak they're
kind of spitting poison and anyone who
even suspects this
there's so much division and people who
are guaranteed to be on the wrong side
of this argument we might find out that
you're on the wrong side of this
argument we might find out that the
other people are on the wrong side of
this argument in the end
how do we move forward how do we heal
from this i think one one thing that has
helped me is taking a step back when
someone says something mean about you or
degrading even or even threatening and
just think
is this person a good scientist like
apart from this origin stuff are they
doing good for the world and once you
recognize the answer is yes then you
have a lot more
spirit of generosity to them
you you no longer feel like they're out
to get me or things like that you're
just like
okay this business said some pretty mean
things about me but that they're forced
for good in another way in another way
for this pandemic even where they're
informing people about novel variants or
public health or things like that and
once once you have that peace of mind
you're like i can take whatever
they say about me
the main thing now is for someone to do
this
job of
facilitating a public international
conference on pathogen research and that
is where my energy is going to focus on
after this book so
i think that there's an order to things
and and we couldn't we cannot have this
conference on regulating pathogen
research without first establishing that
a lab origin is very credible and this
also be investigated because otherwise
how would you have this conference you'd
go there and all the
some of the virologists would be like
why are we even having this conference
don't we know that it's a conspiracy
theory to discuss lab origin so
there's an order to things and now for
me
the noise it fades away and what has to
be done is a new global moratorium a new
framework where it's not the people who
want to do this work are proving
themselves
but
there's much more transparency maybe
relocating the slabs to to a very
beautiful island where they have like
you know international cuisine like the
best like theme parks and like things
like that but the people there have very
good quarantine measures to protect the
other seven billion of us so i think
um there are things that have to be done
we shouldn't wait for the next pandemic
there isn't a timer there's not like one
pandemic a century now we wait 100 years
like we don't know when the next one
could be we don't want to be the next
wuhan no city wants to be the next wuhan
which is under suspicion so let's let's
do a good job let's tidy up our research
uh make sure that everything is done
above the surface of the water so we're
not just seeing the tip of the iceberg
of all these dangerous pathogen research
activities i want to encourage people to
be forgiving once we find out what the
truth is to be forgiving to people who
are on the wrong side of this argument
and even people who were toxic on the
wrong side of this argument because
we have there's a culture now where we
just
someone makes one bad mistake
and they everything they've done gets
dismissed
and in reality that's not how things are
people are
people can be really obnoxious on one
issue
but they're good people and they're
doing good things and like we need to be
able to forgive people and recognize
people's contributions we need to get
away from this idea that either all of
your ideas are are good or none of your
ideas are good you know
this is this is a complicated situation
this is the first time that all of us
are dealing with this yeah uh
we just need to be
we need to forgive each other and we
need to move on
once we figure out what the heck
happened here so
thank you so much for your time this was
really a pleasure for me i've been
following your twitter for a while and
i've been very careful as to who i would
want to have on a talk about this i've
been seeing how you've been dealing with
criticism i've i've seen that
the few times you did get
overly edgy or accusatory you
you toned it down immediately it's very
difficult in this situation to stay calm
and to stay rational and you've done
such an incredible job
thank you for the work that you're doing
i feel bad about
all the crap you've been getting
i am optimistic that we're going to
figure this out and that things will
heal and
we're going to make the scientific
community better we're going to make
virology research safer
and we're going to prevent something
like this from happening in the future
so
yeah i really enjoyed this conversation
like we got really deep into some of
these scientific questions and about
science and society i am full of hope
and so are many other scientists and
then public health people and science
and society fellows like we we know that
there's a lot of work to do
but there are people who are willing to
do it and they're not going to be shut
down by pessimism we're not going to be
told that no point in investigating how
could you guys ever find it or no point
improving the journalists like
publishing system
no there's tons of things we can do and
we should be doing it um
this virus did not end us like we we can
learn from it we can make science and
journalism and public leadership so much
better and
the next time a virus shows up maybe
we'll be able to contain it within the
week right so like the things we can do
we shouldn't we shouldn't just give up
well that was it that's dr alina chan
what a rock star huh
amazing amazing woman
i want to end reading to you what i
wrote back
way back in 2020
right after i published my first
animation i wrote an article about
the
lab league possibility because i was
getting you know so much crap from my
audience
and i want to read to you
the ending of that
article
you can be the judge as to whether or
not it's still relevant today over here
on statedclearly.com did the new
coronavirus come from a lab here's what
i said at the end
now what
first off i recommend that all nations
look at ways to prevent the likeliness
of future spillover events from wild and
domestic animals in china this may mean
changing how wet markets are run and
doing a better job to enforce current
poaching laws
in the u.s it might mean requiring
hunters to take disease prevention
lessons before obtaining hunting
licenses it might require more
transparency in factory farms
well i have great respect for the
research done at the wuhan institute of
virology i do agree with those calling
for an in-depth investigation about a
leak little side note at that time
i'm pretty sure that the only people
that were calling for an in-depth
investigation
were politicians
i don't think that the scientists had
really jumped on board and vocalized yet
there were politicians mostly
republicans
that were calling for this i am not a
republican
but i don't have any problem listening
to them when it seems like they're right
about something and it seemed like they
were right about this to me
continuing on
furthermore at this time i recommend we
all review lab protocols around the
world including the united states to
think that a leak is only a possibility
for labs in china would be absolute
hubris
two of the labs holding the most
dangerous pathogens in the world
are currently located in atlanta georgia
one is at the centers for disease
control and prevention the other is at
georgia state university atlanta is a
city hosting half a million people in
one of the world's largest international
airports is this risk appropriate
in conclusion no matter how the virus
really got its start what's most
important is that we all work together
to stop its spread doing so requires
international cooperation
if direct evidence of foul play or a
horrible accident is eventually detected
let us respond with forgiveness
and work together
to move on
that's still how i feel
that
that
that's still the way that i feel about
this
let's just fix this problem
and let's just move on
now
let me be clear so i'm not misunderstood
the time for forgiveness has not yet
arrived
right now we need to do whatever it
takes to figure out what happened and we
need to do whatever it takes to make
sure that it never happens again but
once this problem has been solved
and as soon as it is clear to the world
that this will not be acceptable in the
future revenge becomes pointless
a lot of people
are going to be
discovered to have been on the wrong
side of this argument once this is all
figured out let's just [ __ ] move on
let it be i mean i maybe that's
totally naive of me this thing is going
to be costing trillions and trillions of
dollars by the time it's over and a lot
of people have died
but but what's the point of adding piss
to vinegar
you